Let's get started.
So good morning everyone.
My name is Aviva and today we're going
to learn about how deep learning can be
used to build systems capable of
perceiving images and making decisions
based on visual information.
Neural networks have really made a
tremendous impact in this area over the
past 20 years and I think to really
appreciate how and why this has been the
case.
It helps to take a step back way back to
540 million years ago.
And the Cambrian explosion where
biologists trace the evolutionary
origins of vision.
The reason vision seems so easy for us
as humans is because we have had 540
million years of data for evolution to
train on.
Compare that to bipedal movement,
human language,
and the difference is significant.
Starting in around the 19 sixties,
there was a surge in interest,
um,
in,
in both the neuro basis of vision and in
developing methods to systematically
characterize visual processing.
And this eventually led to computer
scientists wondering about how these
findings from neuroscience could be
applied to artificial intelligence.
And one of the biggest breakthroughs in
our understanding of the neural basis of
vision came from to scientists as a
Harvard Hubel and wiesel,
and they had a pretty simple
experimental setup where they were,
where they were able to measure visual,
a neural activity in the visual Cortex
of cats by recording directly from the
electrical signals from neurons in this
region of the brain.
They displayed a simple stimulus on a
screen and then probed the visual Cortex
to see which neurons fired in response
to that stimulus.
There were a few key takeaways from this
experiment that I'd like you to keep in
mind as we go through today's lecture.
The first was that they found that there
was an mechanism for spatial invariance.
They could record neural responses to
particular patterns,
and this was constant regardless of the
location of those patterns on the
screen.
The second was that the neurons they
recorded from had what they called a
receptive field.
They certain neurons only responded to
certain regions of the input while
others responded to other regions.
Finally,
they were able to tease out that there
was a mapping,
a hierarchy to neuro neuro organization
in the visual cortex.
There are cells that are responded to
more simple images such as rods and
rectangles,
and then downstream layers of neurons.
They use the activations from these
upstream neurons in their computation,
so cognitive scientists and
neuroscientists have since built off
this early work to indeed confirm that
the visual Cortex is organized into
layers and this hierarchy of layers
allows for the recognition of
increasingly complex features that,
for example,
allow us to immediately recognize the
face of a friend.
So now that we've gotten a sense at a
very high level of how our brains
process visual information,
we can turn our attention to what
computers see.
How does it computer processing and
image well to a computer.
Images are just numbers.
So suppose we have a picture of Abraham
Lincoln.
It's made up of pixels and since this is
a gray scale image,
each of these pixels can be represented
by just a single number.
So we can represent our image as a two d
array of numbers.
One for each pixel in the image,
and if we were to have an rgb color
image,
not gray scale,
we can represent that with a three d
array where we have two d matrices for
each of our G and b.
Now that we have a way to represent
images to computers,
we can next think about what types of
computer vision tasks we can perform and
in machine learning more broadly,
we can think of tasks of regression and
those of classification in regression.
Our output takes a continuous value and
in classification,
a single class label.
So let's consider the task of image
classification.
We want to predict a single label for a
given input image.
For example,
let's say we have a bunch of images of
us presidents and we want to build a
classification pipeline to tell us which
president is an image.
I'll putting the probability that the
image is of a particular president.
So in order to be able to classify these
images are pipeline needs to be able to
tell what is unique about a picture of
Lincoln versus a picture of Washington
versus a picture of Obama.
And another way to think about this
problem at a,
at a high level is in terms of the
features that are characteristic of a
particular class of images,
classification would then be done by
detecting the presence of these features
in a given image.
If the,
if the feature is for a particular
image,
are all present in an image,
we can then predict that class with a
high probability.
So for our image classification
pipeline,
our model needs to know first what the
features are and secondly it needs to be
able to detect those features in an
image.
So one way we can solve this is to
leverage our knowledge about a
particular field and use this to
manually define the features ourselves
and classification pipeline would then
try to detect these mentally defined
features in images and use the results
of some detection algorithm for
classification.
But there's a big problem with this
approach.
Remember that images are just 3d arrays
of brightness,
values and image data has a lot of
variation.
Occlusion variations in illumination,
viewpoint variation,
interclass variation,
and our classification pipeline has to
be invariant to all these variations
while still being sensitive to the
variability between different classes,
even though our pipeline could use
features that we the human define where
this manual extraction would break down
is in the detection task itself,
and this is due to the incredible
variability that I just mentioned.
The detection of these features would
actually be really difficult in practice
because your detection algorithm would
need to withstand each and every one of
these different variations,
so how can we do better?
We want a way to both extract features
and detect their presence in images
automatically in a hierarchical fashion,
and we can use neuro network based
approaches to do exactly this,
to learn visual features directly from
image data and to learn a hierarchy of
these features to construct an internal
representation of the image.
For example,
if we wanted to be able to classify
images of faces,
maybe we could just first learn and
detect low level features like edges and
dark spots,
level features,
eyes,
ears and noses,
and then high level features that
actually resemble facial structure and
neural networks will allow us to
directly learn visual features in this
manner if we construct them cleverly.
So in yesterday's first lecture,
we learned about fully connected neural
networks where you can have multiple
hidden layers and where each neuron in a
given layer is connected to every neuron
in the subsequent layer.
Let's say we wanted to use a fully
connected neural network like the one
you see here for image classification.
In this case,
our input image would be transformed
into a vector of pixel values,
fed into the network,
and each neuron in the hidden layer
would be connected to all neurons in the
input layer.
I hope you can appreciate that all
spatial spatial information from our two
d array would be completely lost
additional weight.
Additionally,
we'd have many,
many parameters because this is a fully
connected network,
so it's not going to be really feasible
to implement such network in practice,
so how can we use the spatial structure
that's inherent in the input to inform
the architecture of our network?
The key insight in how we can do this is
to connect patches of the input
represented as a two d array to neurons
in hidden layers.
This is to say that each neuron in a
hidden layer only sees a particular
region of what the input to that layer
is.
This will not only reduce the number of
weights in our network,
but also allow us to leverage the fact
that in an image pixels that are near
each other are probably somehow related
to define connections across the whole
input.
We can apply this same principle by
sliding the patch window across the
entirety of the input image.
In this case,
by two units in this way will take into
account the spatial structure that's
present,
but remember,
our ultimate task is to learn visual
features and we can do this by smartly
waiting the connections between a patch
of our input to the neuron it's
connected to in the next hidden layer,
so as to detect particular features
present in that input and essentially
what this amounts to is applying the
filter,
a set of weights to extract local
features,
and it would be useful for us in our
classification pipeline to have many
different features to work with and we
can do this by using multiple filters,
multiple sets of weights,
and finally we want to be able to share
the parameters of each filter across all
the connections between the input layer
and the next layer because the features
that matter in one part of the input
should matter elsewhere.
This is the same concept of a spatial
invariants that I alluded to earlier in
practice.
This amounts to a patchy operation known
as convolution.
Let's first think about this at a high
level.
Suppose we have a four by four filter,
which means we have 16 different weights
and we're going to apply the same filter
to four by four patches in the input and
use the result of that operation to
somehow influence the state of the
neuron and the next layer that this
patch is connected to.
Then we're going to shift our filter by
two pixels as for example,
and grabbed the next patch of the input,
so in this way we can start thinking
about convolution at a very high level,
but you're probably wondering how does
this actually work?
What do we mean by features and how does
this convolution operation allow us to
extract them?
Hopefully we can make this concrete by
walking through a couple of examples.
Suppose we want to classify x's from a
set of black and white images of letters
where black is equal to negative one and
why is represented by a value of one.
For classification,
it would clearly not be possible to
simply compare the two matrices to see
if they're equal.
We want to be able to classify an x as
an ex,
even if it's shifted,
shrunk,
rotated,
deform,
transformed in some way.
We want our model to compare the images
of an x piece by piece and look for
these important pieces that define an x
as an x.
those are the features and if our model
can find rough feature matches in
roughly the same positions into
different images,
it can get a lot better at seeing the
similarity between different examples of
xs.
You can think of each feature as many
images,
small two dimensional array of values,
and we're going to use filters to pick
up on the features common to xs in the
case of an ex filters that can pick up
on diagonal lines and crossing will
probably capture all the important
characteristics of most x's.
So no here that these smaller matrices
are the filters of weights that we'll
use in our convolution operation to
detect the corresponding features in an
input image.
So now all that's left is to define this
operation that will pick up on when
these features pop up in our image,
and that operation is convolution
convolution preserves the spatial
relationship between pixels by learning
image features in small squares of the
input.
To do this,
we perform an element wise
multiplication between the filter matrix
and a patch of the input image that's of
the same dimensions as the filter.
This results in a three by three matrix
and the example you see here,
all entries in this matrix are one,
and that's because there's a perfect
correspondence between our filter and
the region of the input that we're
involving it with.
Finally,
we saw them all the entries in this
Matrix get nine and that's the result of
our convolution operation.
Let's consider one more example.
Suppose now we want to compute the
convolution of a five by five image and
a three by three filter.
To do this,
we need to cover the entirety of the
input image by sliding the filter over
the image,
performing the same element wise,
multiplication and addition.
Let's see what this looks like.
We'll first start off in the upper left
corner,
element wise,
multiplied this three by three patch
with the entries of the filter,
and then add this results in the first
entry in our output matrix called the
feature map.
We will next slide the three by three
filter over by one to grab the next
patch and repeat the same operation.
I'm in wise multiplication.
Addition.
This results in the second entry and we
continue in this way until we have
covered the entirety of our five by five
image and that's it.
The feature map reflects where in the
input was activated by this filter that
we applied.
Now that we've gone through the
mechanism of the convolution operation,
let's see how different filters can be
used to produce different feature maps.
So on the left you'll see a picture of a
woman's face and next to it the output
of applying three different
convolutional filters to that same
image.
And you can appreciate that by simply
changing the weights of the filters.
We can detect different features from
the image.
So I hope you can now see how
convolution allows us to capitalize on
the spatial structure inherent to image
data and use sets of weights to extract
local features to end to very easily be
able to detect different types of
features by simply using different
filters.
These concepts of spatial structure and
local feature extraction using
convolution are at the core of the
neural networks used for computer vision
tasks,
which are very appropriately named
convolutional neural networks or CNNS.
So first we'll take a look at a CNN
architecture that's designed for image
classification.
Now there are three main operations to a
CNN first convolutions,
which as we saw can be used to generate
feature maps,
second nonlinearity,
which we learned in the first lecture
yesterday because image data is highly
nonlinear,
and finally pooling which is a
downsampling operation.
In training,
we train our model,
our CNN model,
on a set of images,
and in training we learned the weights
of the convolutional filters that
correspond to feature maps in
convolutional layers.
And in the case of classification,
we can feed the output of these
convolutional layers into a fully
connected layer to perform
classification.
Now we'll go through each of these
operations to break down a the basic
architecture of a CNN.
First,
let's consider the convolution
operation.
As we saw yesterday,
each neuron and the hidden layer will
compute a weighted sum of its inputs,
apply bias,
and eventually activate with a
nonlinearity.
What's special in CNN is this idea of
local connectivity.
Each neuron and hidden layer only sees a
patch of its inputs.
We can now define the actual computation
for a neuron in the hidden layer.
Its inputs are those neurons in the
patch of the input layer that it's
connected to.
We apply a matrix of weights are
convolutional filter four by four.
In this example,
do an element wise multiplication,
add the outputs and apply bias,
so this defines how neurons in
convolutional are connected,
but within a single convolutional layer,
we can have multiple different filters
that we are learning to be able to
extract different features.
And what this means that is that the
output of a convolutional layer has a
volume where the height and the width
are spatial dimensions,
and these spatial dimensions are
dependent on the dimensions of the input
layer.
The dimensions of our filter and how
we're sliding our filter over the input,
the stride,
the depth of a this output volume is
then given by the number of different
filters we apply in that layer.
We can also think of how neurons in
convolutional layers are connected in
terms of the receptive field,
the locations in the original input
image that a node is connected to.
These parameters defined the spatial
arrangement of the output of a
convolutional layer.
The next step is to apply a nonlinearity
to this output volume as was introduced
in yesterday's lecture.
We do this because data is highly
nonlinear and in Cnns it's common
practice to apply nonlinearity after
every convolution operation and the
common activation function that's used
is the value which is a pixel by pixel
operation that will replace all negative
values falling convolution with a zero.
And the last key operation to a CNN is
pulling and pulling is used to reduce
dimension dimension,
yet,
excuse me,
dimensionality,
and to preserve spatial invariance,
a common text technique which you'll
very often see is max pooling as shown
in this example,
and it's exactly what it sounds like.
We simply take the maximum value in a
patch of the input,
in this case,
a two by two patch and that determines
the output of the pooling operation.
And I encourage you to kind of meditate
on other ways in which we could perform
this sort of downsampling operation.
So these are the key operations of a CNN
and we're now ready to put them together
to actually construct our network.
We can layer these operations to learn a
hierarchy of features present in the
image data.
A CNN bills for image classification can
roughly be broken down into two parts.
The first is the feature learning
pipeline where we learn features in
input images through convolution,
through the introduction of nonlinearity
and,
uh,
the pooling operation.
And the second part is how we're
actually performing the classification,
the convolutional and pooling layers
output,
high level features of the input data,
and we can these into fully connected
layers to perform the actual
classification.
And the output of the fully connected
layers in practice is a probability
distribution for an input images
membership over set of possible classes.
And a common way to do this is using a
function called soft Max,
where the output represents this
categorical probability distribution.
Now that we've gone through all the
components of a CNN,
all that's left is to discuss how to
train him.
Again,
we'll go back to a CNN for image
classification.
During training we learned the weights
of the convolutional filters.
What features the network is detecting,
and in this case will also learn the
weights of the fully connected layers.
Since the output for classification is a
probability distribution,
we can use cross entropy loss for
optimization with back prop.
Okay,
so I'd like to take a closer look at CNN
for classification and discuss what is
arguably the most famous example of of a
CNN,
the the ones trained and tested on the
image net dataset.
Image net is a massive data set with
over 14 million images spanning 20,000
different categories.
For example,
there are 1,409
different pictures of bananas in this
data set alone.
Even better,
bananas are succinctly described as an
elongated,
crushing shaped yellow fruit with soft,
sweet flesh,
which both gives a pretty good
descriptive value of what a banana is
and speaks to its deliciousness.
So the creators of the image net dataset
also have created a set of visual
recognition challenges on this Dataset.
And what's most famous is the image net
classification task where users are
challengers are simply tasked with
producing a list of the object
categories present in a given image.
Oh,
across 1000 different categories.
And the results of,
of that neural networks have had on this
classification task are pretty
remarkable.
Two thousand 12 was the first time a CNN
one.
This challenge with the famous,
uh,
Alex Net cnn,
and since then neural networks have
dominated the competition and the error
has kept decreasing,
surpassing human error in 2015 with the
resonant architecture.
But with improved accuracy,
the number of layers in these networks
has been increasing quite dramatically.
So there's a trade off here,
right?
Build your network deeper.
How deep can you go?
So,
so far we've talked only about using
CNNS for image classification,
but in reality,
this idea of using convolutional layers
to extract features can extend to a
number of different applications.
When we considered a CNN for
classification,
we saw that we could think of it in two
parts,
feature learning and the classification.
What is at the core of the of
convolutional neural networks is is the
feature learning pipeline.
After that,
we can really change what follows to
suit the application that we desire.
For example,
the portion following the convolutional
layers may look different for different
image classification domains.
We can also introduce new architectures
beyond fully connected layers for tasks
such as segmentation and image
captioning.
So today I'd like to go through three
different applications of CNNS beyond
image classification,
semantic segmentation,
where the task is to assign each pixel
in an image and object class to produce
a segmentation of that image object
detection,
where we are tasked with detecting
instances of semantic objects in an
image and image captioning where the
task is to generate a short description
of the image that captures it's semantic
content.
So first,
let's talk about semantic segmentation
with fully convolutional networks or
fcns.
Here the network again,
takes a image input of arbitrary size,
but instead it has to produce a
correspondingly sized output where each
pixel has been assigned a class label,
which we can then visualize as a
segmentation as we saw before with CNNS
for image classification,
we first have a series of convolutional
layers that are downsampling operations
for feature extraction,
and this results in a hierarchy of
learned features.
Now the difference is that we have a
series of upsampling operations to
increase the resolution of our output
from the fully from the convolutional
layers,
and to then combine this output of the
upsampling operations with those from
our downsampling path to produce a
segmentation.
One application of this sort of
architecture is to the real time
segmentation of the driving scene here.
The network has this encoder,
decoder architecture for encoding the
architecture is very similar to what we
discussed earlier,
earlier,
convolutional layers to learn a
hierarchy of feature maps,
and then the decoder portion of the
network actually uses the indices from
pooling operations to up sample from
these feature maps.
And output a segmentation,
another way CNNS have been extended and
applied is for object detection where
we're trying to learn features that
characterize particular regions of the
input and then classify those regions.
The original pipeline for doing this
called our CNN is pretty straightforward
given an input image.
The algorithm extracts region proposals,
bottom up,
computes features for each of these
proposals using convolutional layers and
then classifies each region proposal,
but there's a huge downside to this.
So in their.
In their original pipeline,
this group extracted about 2000
different region proposals,
which meant that they had to run 2000
CNNS for feature extraction.
So since then there.
And that takes a really,
really long time.
So since then there have been extensions
of this basic idea,
one being to first run the CNN on the
input image to first extract features
and then get region proposals from the
feature maps.
Finally,
let's consider image captioning.
So suppose we're given an image of a cat
riding the skateboard in classification,
our task is to output a class label for
this image cap,
and as we've probably hammered home by
now,
this is done by feeding our input image
through a set of convolutional layers,
extracting features,
and then passing these features onto
fully connected layers.
To predict a label.
Image captioning,
we want to generate a sentence that
describes the semantic content of the
same image.
So let's take the same network from
before and remove the fully connected
layers at the end.
Now we only have convolutional layers to
extract features and we'll replace the
fully connected layers with a recurrent
neural network.
The output of the convolutional layers
gives us a fixed length encoding of the
features present in our input image,
which we can use to initialize and rnn
that we can then train to predict the
words that describe this image I'm using
using the rnn.
So now that we've talked about
convolutional neural networks,
they're applications.
We can introduce some tools that have
recently been been designed to probe and
visualize the inner workings of a CNN to
get at this question of what is the
network actually seeing.
So first off,
a few years ago,
there was a paper that published an
interactive visualization tool of a
convolutional neural network trained on
a Dataset of handwritten digits,
a very famous dataset called feminist,
and you can play around with this tool
to the behavior of the network given a
number that you yourself drawn in and
what you're seeing here is the feature
maps for this seven that someone has
drawn in and as we can see in the first
layer,
the first six filters are showing
primarily edge detection and deeper
layers will start to pick up on corners,
crosses,
curves,
more complex features,
the exact hierarchy that that we
introduced in the beginning of this
lecture.
A second method which you'll you
yourself will have the chance to play
around with in the second lap is called
class activation.
Maps or cans,
cans generate a heat map that indicates
the regions have an image to which are
CNN for classification attends to in its
final layers,
and the way that this is computed is is
the following.
We choose an output class that we want
to visualize.
We can then obtain the weights from the
last fully connected layer because these
represent the importance of each of the
final feature maps.
In outputting that class,
we can compute our heat map as simply a
weighted combination of each of the
final convolutional feature maps.
Using the weights from the last fully
connected layer,
we can apply cams to visualize both the
activation maps for the most likely
predictions of an object class for one
image as you see on the left,
and also to visualize the image regions
used by the CNN to identify in different
instances of one object class.
As you see on the right.
So to conclude this talk,
I'd like to take a brief consideration
of how deep learning for computer vision
has really made an impact over the past
several years and the advances that have
been made in deep learning for computer
vision would really not be possible
without the availability,
availability of large and well annotated
image data sets.
And this has really facilitated the
progress that's been made.
Some datasets include image net,
which we discussed amness a data data
Dataset of handwritten digits,
which was used in some of the first big
CNN papers,
places a database from here at mit of
scenes and landscapes and cipher 10,
which contains images from 10 different
categories listed here.
The impact has been broad and deep,
um,
and spanning a variety of,
of different fields.
Everything from medicine to self driving
cars to security.
One area in which convolutional neural
networks really made a big impact early
on was in facial recognition software.
And if you think about it nowadays,
this software is pretty much ubiquitous
from social media to security systems.
Another area that's generate,
generated a lot of excitement as of late
is in autonomous vehicles.
And self driving cars,
so Nvidia has a research team working on
a CNN based system for end to end
control of self driving cars,
their pipeline pizza,
single image from a camera on the car to
a CNN that directly outputs a single
number,
which is the steering is the predicted
steering wheel angle and the man you see
in this video is actually one of our
guests lecturers and on Thursday we'll
hear about how his team is,
is developing this platform.
Finally,
we've also seen a significant impact in
the medical field where deep learning
models have been applied to the analysis
of a whole host of different types of
medical images.
Just this past year,
a team from Stanford developed a CNN
that could achieve dermatologists level
classification of skin lesions.
So you could imagine,
and this is what they actually did,
having an app on your phone where you
take a picture,
upload that picture to the APP.
It's fed into a CNN that jen,
that then generates a prediction of
whether or not that lesion is reason for
concern.
So to summarize what we've covered in
today's lecture,
we first considered the origins of the
computer vision problem,
how we can represent images as arrays of
pixel values and what convolutions are,
how they work.
We then discussed the basic architecture
of CNNS and finally we extended this to
consider some different applications,
um,
of,
of convolutional neural networks,
and also talked a bit about how we can
visualize their behavior.
So,
with that,
I'd like to conclude,
um,
I'm happy to take questions after the
lecture portion is over.
It's now my pleasure to introduce our
next speaker,
a special guest professor Aaron
[inaudible] from the University of
Montreal.
Professor Kerrville is one of the
creators of generative adversarial
networks,
and he'll be talking to us about deep
generative models and their
applications.
So please join me in welcoming him.